a prime minister in war times trying to
meet the moment and putting his navy on
alert and we're going to need you out
there
doing a lot of stuff as fast as possible
camel led shipyard in merseyside a base
that's been building military ships for
hundreds of years if i just push this
forward nothing will happen nothing will
happen
nothing will happen on board here
perhaps but grave warnings from this
prime minister about what could happen
next in ukraine
as russian officials today continue to
dismiss military attacks on civilians
lavrov said concerns over civilian
casualties were to quote him pathetic
shrieks you know but i'm afraid that is
just where they are and
that is what we're dealing with and i'll
i'll make you one other prediction by
the way which is that the stuff that
you're hearing about uh
chemical weapons is straight out of
their playbook they start saying that uh
there are chemical weapons uh that have
been stored by
their opponents or by the americans and
so when they themselves deploy uh
chemical weapons as i as i fear they
they may they have us
a sort of a mask you're of cour a fake
story ready to go
the use of chemical weapons by the
syrian government backed at the time by
the kremlin devastated so many but sadly
two it became a powerful tool in the
armory of an aggressor i do share the
prime minister's concerns in this area
it is very similar to what we've seen
um in syria and that is why i think
we're all concerned of these irregular
weapons we've seen that the vacuum bombs
the thermobaric bombs being used to
devastating effect
and uh now we're hoping we're hoping
that we won't see chemical weapons but
but they've been so successful in syria
it's um it's hard to see that putin
wouldn't do two weeks into the invasion
of ukraine and this prime minister's not
convinced there's much chance of
de-escalation when it comes to president
putin you can't see a way out at the
moment i can't see a way out that
doesn't begin with the realization uh by
the uh the kremlin that they made a
catastrophic mistake
i think that vladimir putin has himself
made it very difficult
to
find an off-ramp and he has i think
uh
driven his uh his tanks so to speak down
a a cul-de-sac from which it will be
very hard to extricate himself this week
the ukrainian president told sky news
the west was indecisive refusing to shut
ukrainian skies ruling out implementing
a no-fly zone is it not on your
conscience every time you speak to
president zielenski and he asks you for
that no-fly zone i gotta say it's
absolutely terrible it's absolutely
agonizing and i've had this conversation
uh
at least a couple of times now with with
vladimir
but i think the difficulty is that it
would require me
to order
raf jets uk pilots
into the air with a mission
to shoot down russian fast jets
and that is something that
all my life
literally all my life or my childhood i
remember something that we
uh we did everything we possibly could
to avert we've had some some
very frank conversations and ones in
which which have been deeply
upsetting
frank conversations only likely to get
more difficult these moments now are
without precedence and with no end in
sight beth rigby sky news